we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p the
voicemail line is made possible by our
good friends at linguist which is a
simple and super effective language
learning app with a clean easy-to-use
interface they use AI algorithms to
recognize your weaknesses and help you
learn a language more quickly i've been
using it to brush up on my french with
much success you can try it out for free
no credit card needed at linguist
dot-com slash Pakman that's ling vist
with a v.com slash Pakman here's a
voicemail with a very strong assertion
about the future of the presidency of
the United States take a listen to this
and through yang will be the next
president
he has a strange amount of Orem the
conservative sized and then a great
amount of support on the Democratic side
you know from actual people so it's it
just reminds me a lot of Trump he has a
crazy amount of support on both sides
and he's just gonna win he's gonna be
the next person people are meaning about
it gonna be an ex-president and yeah
yeah
so Andrew yang has been rising and and
very quickly his ideas are appealing to
some libertarians his ideas are
appealing to some on the Left there is
more criticism lately of Andrew yang
from the left critiques of his
particular position on college tuition
critiques of the particular way that he
is laying out his universal basic income
plan but the in the immediate Andrew
yang is rising his name recognition is
growing he has gotten a number of
mainstream sort of corporate media
interviews and he is raising more and
more money now what's important to
remember is in order to be on the ballot
in November of 2020 you first have to
win the Democratic primary so if people
on the right or the middle are liking
Andrew yang many of them don't vote in
the Democratic primary so they can help
them by donating money which of course
is a big thing but it's unclear whether
that axe
helps him secure votes in a direct way
in the Democratic primary
so the claim that he will be the next
president statistically speaking you're
probably not likely to win that bet
although anything is possible i'm
personally super interested super
interested in seeing what the next three
months
hold for andrew Yang's candidacy and by
the way Pat are we is he no longer doing
our show because he's too big now he's
been doing our show for a year and we
seem to be unable to get him back on now
that he's a big shot yeah so we've had
him on twice I'm in contact with one of
his people and we want to have him on
again soon but you're right he's on he's
on Joe Rogan he's on MSNBC and all these
cable outlets I hope he's not getting
too big for us but if he is getting too
big for us I guess that means that his
candidacy is taking off and that's good
news in some respect yeah I I would um I
would appreciate it if he came back on
the show because we've been talking
about him for a year and our clips with
him have some have hundreds of thousands
of views at this point maybe people
should politely tweet him and say hey
you're going back on the David Pakman
show right because he he was
interviewing you before all of these
other people that would be maybe a nice
thing to do because I would love to get
him back on and dig deeper into some of
his policy ideas we've got a great bonus
show coming up for you today make sure
that you are a member or a patron to get
instant access to the bonus show I'll
speak to you then